I drank too much got in the hot tub
chilled out I mean where's your hot tub
just you know my house a little hot tub
fell asleep a little bit woke up wow f
wildy with everything happening in the
Middle East right now with everything
happening your birthday what are you and
my birthday what are you even talking
about what are you referencing you're
not my
friend what are you talking about my
yeah that's not a very friendly comment
to all I was he couldn't be referencing
friends it's a black guy here yeah
exactly that's a good ass point this
nothing
they would never Dr
what season two that happens to every
character wait a minute wait are you
referencing Matthew Perry's death who's
that oh thank God guys thank God it's
just a coincidence what he was talking
about oh okay oh my God I guess you
didn't know that that's why you made
that really off-color joke what are you
talking about yeah Matthew Perry who's
an actor from the famous show Friends
has passed away tragically tragically he
died in a hot tub just like what you
were talking about but clearly not
exactly cuz you don't even watch TV you
don't even know that show so you weren't
trying to make some edgy joke you edge
Lord call Lord this is a great title I
like that what did happen with Matthew
Perry man this is so tragic it's sad yo
I'm I'm a big friends fan we know this
I'm sad about this yeah this guy died in
the hot tub struggleing with drugs his
whole life we don't know what happened
we're still trying to figure it out but
Mark is full full-blown conspiracy
theory on this a lot of people have been
talking I don't think this this is crazy
have you seen his most recent Instagram
post oh no don't tell me it's something
with a hot tub it's something with a hot
tub there's no way there's something
with a hot tub shifting I it just seems
strange to me I don't know hot tub and
then what the caption just says I don't
know what happened all respect to him
and his family but it also is weird oh
no no no no no oh so warm water swrl
around makes you feel good I'm Matt man
what him in a hot tub I'm just saying
bro it's a huge got tub by the way this
guy got ni got a nice tub overing La
who's taking that
picture I don't George Soros probably
[__] Illuminati is that him in the
corner yeah oh okay I thought it was
just oh with the Beats on yeah okay so
what do we think happened here oh
somebody killed him yeah might do you
think you think it was a murder yeah
why look at the evidence that's all the
evidence we need
right look at the evidence guys we
shouldn't be joking around about this
I'm not laughing at his death I'm
laughing at this look at the evidence
come on man figure s about can can I ask
an honest question because I think the
outfit is very creative and cool
okay this is an honest question act
already it's
not ready I have no act outs I just want
to let you know okay so I'm already
prepared to just stop at the bomb okay
okay I'm not going to act it out okay I
just need to understand
stands if this is like a paid
thing you don't have a relationship with
I do have relationship with the okay and
then is this part of Halloween cuz it is
Halloween we're filming this on
Halloween yeah let's say I'm scarecrow
okay here we go I could do you could
pass the Scarecrow if I do some [__] on
right now yeah uhoh run it back run it
back
father R it
back I helped you I help what are you
doing there are you doing like a
sack I helped you out right there I
helped you out bro oh man [__] you guys
honestly that was a good
joke what the
[__] I don't know you guys are pulling a
prank we're not pulling a prank we're
trying why is nobody making fun of
Alex's outfit that's what I need to know
why have you guys sitting here on the
couch it's very out there but it's also
kind of flu what I say first thing what
I'm saying so it's like it's hard to
make F he bombed so bad got on our heads
let's get out of our heads we have to
get out he bombs so bad stop affecting
us cuz if if we go at it you have got to
go perfect or else it's I don't want to
be what would you say hold on what would
you say if what if AOS showed up dressed
like a human
trafficked
damn help me no no don't act don't act
take me back to my family take me back
to my family in Eastern Europe is that
no okay okay okay what if Akash came
dressed up as that what would we say is
this yeah that could be my outfit for
real that could be my Halloween outfit
bosy rice Indian bag of rice there you
go that's what I'm doing I mean his hips
did look like that for a while yeah like
a bag of rice for a minute honestly yeah
it's we were talking about this before
the Pod how how miserable you are and I
need you to just be honest with the
people are you more miserable now that
you're skinny no I'm not it's just not
fun I'm being honest it's not fun trying
to be skinny but more you can't even
stay awake well that's cuz I have a cold
good
luck so there's no negative side effects
to oh dude we had a fantastic dinner
last night at a place I've wanted to eat
at for a long time oh fantastic shouts
and then they uh we're just passing
delicious plate after delicious plate
and every time I didn't know if I can
say shout yeah I said shouts and I was
like wait Am I who ordered the paparazzi
got Paparazzi that was crazy who ordered
the papar prize Pi also use a promo code
Schultz you get your initial deposit
matched up to $100 that mean you put in
100 you get 100 for free so you might as
well just do it respect shout out prize
picks man